mobilier gonflable couleurs et formes
improbables pas de doute nous avons
remonté le temps où le plastique et la
bacélite font irruption dans notre
quotidien et révolutionnent même nos
modes de consommation bienvenue dans les
années 70 à l'occasion des 40 ans du
quartier du Pont du routtoir à
guillancour la ville propose à ses
habitants de revivre un moment
d'histoire à travers la reconstitution
partielle d'un appartement de l'époque
dans cet appartement on peut donc
découvrir toutes les pièces qui
contiennent des
du mobilier qui donc caractéristique de
ces annéeslà c'est plus une évocation
des années 70 qu'une reconstitution
réaliste réalisé grâce aux collections
du musée de la ville de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline les visites ont permis au
nostalgiques de redécouvrir l'esthétique
caractéristique de la fin des 30
glorieuses et d'initier les plus jeunes
aux tendances
colorées
on a reçu évidemment beaucoup de de
classes de toutes ces écoles de de
guillancour qui ont pu découvrir donc
tout tout ce mobilier toutes ces formes
ces couleurs qui sont vraiment celles
que de qu'on connu leurs parents voir
leurs grands-parents et et donc cette
cette exposition leur a permis vraiment
de s'initier à cette esthétique euh et
et puis aussi de de retrouver voilà des
le côté ludique du design de l'époque à
la fois esthétique et pratique il y a
des donc des motifs qui qui sont
vraiment très caractéristiques et qui
les ont frappé parfois ces enfants
avaient vraiment envie de de retrouver
de vivre dans cet appartement euh donc
finalement l'esthétique ludique et
colorée
euh a été vraiment très voilà les a les
a enchanté pour la plupart et ils
étaient très réceptifs en tout cas on a
eu de très bons retours puisque les
habitants du quartier ont pu ont eu la
chance de retrouver donc ces archives à
travers les films avec en se retrouvant
parfois même dans ces films des proches
et et donc ça fait partie voilà d'une
histoire l'histoire d'un quartier c'est
l'histoire d'une presque une grande
famille en quelque
sorte